[Music]
i'll use my forklift to lift it out so
we can get it to the board
what do you think sal
i think
i think
i think you're the heartiest helper who
has ever helped anyone with their heart
thank you thank you thank you
i'm lauren long and i'm an author and an
illustrator for children's picture books
hi i'm otis otis is a friendly little
tractor
he has a big heart we can do this
together sometimes he can do it on his
own sometimes it takes teamwork i can
help you we'll help too he's a tractor
who works hard and plays hard and that's
a beautiful thing
[Music]
i wrote the first self-titled book just
as a one-off story i had no idea that it
was something that would really resonate
and find an audience
[Music]
ron get rolling with otis they actually
created a piece of otis motor that's in
the shape of a heart and you wouldn't
really notice it until otis feels and so
children will see otis recognize
something and feel it can i help
and then compassion comes in
compassionate action
otis is not just an observer but he's
also a doer let's get rolling
the theme through all of get rolling
with otis
is the unselfishness and the ability for
otis to feel what it's like to be one of
the animals and to care for his friends
the ability to walk in someone else's
shoes is such a great strength and if we
can model empathy and teach empathy to
children then i think
we can change the world a little bit
empathy is a superpower otis teaches
young children that they can make a
difference if they just take a moment to
notice somebody else's feelings then
they can put on their own breaks stop
and go oh how would i feel if that
happened to me can you help me
i could try
otis can be the model that helps our
kids learn that empathy is doable and
empathy is strong and powerful thanks
otis
we're so happy to have friends like you
[Music]
i was trying to model the behavior of
goodness and kindness and caring for
others
to have a part in this television
project i wanted to make sure the heart
of otis was in that show on our farm we
all help each other
[Music]
you